ULFAR ERLINGSSON: My name
is Ulfar Earlingsson.
I'm in Infrastructure
Security here at Google.
And this is the second
"Authors at Google"
talk I host about banking.
Now my interest there
is probably, primarily,
that I'm from
Iceland originally.
And three of the six largest
bankruptcies in history
are Icelandic banks.
And that happened like in 2008
so it's relatively recent.
Now it's my great
pleasure to introduce
Anat Admati from the
Stanford Business School
where she's a professor
of finance and economics.
And she's going to tell
us about the main reason
why those Icelandic
banks failed.
And the main reason
is still around.
It hasn't been fixed in any way.
And it's also explained
in her book, "The Bankers'
New Clothes," which Nadine
from Books Incorporated
is selling here for $5.
So that's a pretty good price.
Anyway with that, I'll
leave the floor to Anat.
ANAT ADMATI: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Thank you, everybody.
I'm thrilled to be here.
I dropped "The Bankers' New
Clothes" from this title.
This is the subtitle
of the book,
"What's Wrong with Banking
and What to Do about It."
Because "The
Bankers' New Clothes"
is about exposing
all the nonsense.
But if we started there,
we would never quite
finish because there
is a lot of it.
And I'll hint at that
at some point later on.
Why we're here.
Why all this obvious stuff
I'm saying is not understood.
Because people don't want you
to understand it, basically.
Or maybe they don't
understand it themselves.
I can't quite ever tell.
So anyway, let's
start with-- so this
is going to start very serious.
We're hitting right
there, as opposed
to how I came to even
be here and explain
these things to anybody
who would listen.
What's wrong with banking?
So let me start
with a diagnosis.
What's wrong with banking?
Well there's a whole
long list here.
What's wrong with banking?
It's a very, very fragile
system, highly interconnected,
lots of risks that's entirely
unnecessary in this system,
and that's a distortion
to the whole economy.
Meaning things just inefficient.
Lots of governance problems.
Governance problems
are basic problems
where somebody makes a decision
and the other person who's
impacted doesn't
have control over it.
That's a basic
governance problem.
And because this
is a system that
doesn't work if
you leave it alone,
it requires good regulation.
And part of the
problem with it is
it's not regulated
effectively to make
it better, to help it to
from itself, basically,
or from the people in it.
And as a result of that, it
doesn't support the economy.
It's part of the
infrastructure, you could say,
of the economy that's just
not working very well.
What makes it so fragile?
Well the first thing--
and the one of them
that I'm going to
talk about a lot--
is that there's just a lot of
reliance on dept in the system.
Just a lot of borrowing.
The way banks and
many, many institutions
fund what they do is
borrow money, make promises
to pay later.
And not just any money.
They promise to
depositors that they
can get their money anytime.
They promise overnight
creditors that they
can get their money tomorrow.
They promise lots of people.
And there is not enough
ability in the system
to absorb the losses
should they happen.
So and then it's
all interconnected.
In other words, I owe you,
and you owe somebody else,
but then somebody
else might owe me,
and so it's all
very interconnected.
And the regulation has
enormous flaws in it.
The way it's
structured, the way it's
measured, the way they can get
around it, all of those things
make this regulation basically
incredibly ineffective.
So here is sort of
a system for you.
This system has this-- they'll
call it shadow banking.
There are lots of
institutions outside,
other institutions
inter-connected with it
in numerous ways.
If you kind of
step back from it,
and there's somebody putting
money in the bank and somebody
borrowing money somewhere,
and we have inter-mediation
in between them, somehow
there's numerous layers there.
And I think that in
the talk about Iceland,
you saw how
interconnected systems can
get with self-dealing
and self-ownership
and lending to
yourself and all that.
The question for society,
of course, is going to be
is there value generated in
every one of these places
that somehow has a reason
for existing in this world?
Somebody wanted to create this
institution outside the balance
sheet of this bank, or
outside somewhere else,
and interacting in another layer
with the rest of the system.
Are we sure that's
a good thing to have
such a complicated system?
So then when the system gets to
be like this-- very fragile--
you get these contagion
effects, these dominoes,
and all of that.
And so you touch something and
the whole system can crumble.
What does it mean, touch it?
In 2008, what
touched it-- or 2007,
it started-- what
touched it was a decline.
A bubble burst in
housing in the US.
In the grand scheme of
things, not a big thing.
There were a lot
of bad loans made.
Some borrowers defaulted.
It was not an
amount of money that
should take down
the global economy.
And yet the system
was so fragile it
couldn't withstand that.
A bankruptcy of one institution
like Lehman Brothers
just sent this whole
thing to implosion.
Well, what are we
going to do about it?
There are proposals
all over the place.
One of them is
about the failure.
So the bankruptcy
doesn't work, let's
find a better way to fail them.
So if they can't
pay their debts,
they'll fail like other people.
The problem with
that is they're very
global-- I'll show
you an interconnected
map across the world-- and they
live globally but die locally.
So to die, if you have 2,000
subsidiaries, each one of these
has to go into a
bankruptcy procedure,
depending on the law in that
country and that's a mess.
And that's what
happened with Lehman.
This bankruptcy-- 80
different bankruptcy
processes or more
started over the world.
And it took years, it's
still barely done since then.
And meanwhile, it freezes
everything and all of that.
Banks can't kind
of go through that.
So no matter how I'm
involved in the effort,
it's part of the reform to have
the FDIC, the Federal Deposit
Insurance Corporation, take down
JP Morgan-- good luck to all
of us if that happens.
These banks are much bigger than
Lehman was, and good luck to us
if we should go into that.
So that's not a great solution.
The other is, let's make
sure that we kind of
make them smaller and somehow
restrict what they can do.
The problem with that--
so we have various,
you might hear these words,
Volcker Rule, you can't do this
and you can do that
and all of that.
And these are potentially--
you talk about Glass-Steagall,
I can't go into all of that.
I'd be happy to talk
a little bit about it.
We used to have a separation
between investment banks
and commercial banks,
deposit-taking institutions.
If you take deposits, you can
only do this and not that.
That's a tough subject.
The problem is it might help,
but if they remain fragile,
and there's more layers and more
different little institutions,
they can still be
failing at the same time
or causing each other
to fail together.
So you might not get rid of
that fragility of this system
by some kind of structural
reform of who can do what.
So you're not going to
the heart of the problem,
to the heart of that fragility.
And you could say, I'm not
going to bail them out,
I hate bailouts.
There were a lot of bailouts,
meaning creditors got paid when
the bank couldn't-- AIG, Citi,
Bear Stearns, many other banks.
Or the government
just invested in them
so they could pay their debts.
Troubled Asset Relief
Program, other things.
The problem with trying
to say, I wrote in the law
that I won't bail you out
is that, if the time comes
and it's better to
bail them out than not,
then you'll have
an emergency law.
And it's hard for governments
to commit to that.
They probably even
shouldn't commit.
They should do what's best.
But it's kind of a
hostage situation.
In other words, you
can't quite commit
to what you'd like to commit.
Here is a network for you.
Just the width of the
line-- this is just,
I picked up
yesterday, so I don't
show you the same
diagram as Iceland--
but this is across
the globe for sure.
20 countries and how the
flows of moneys between them.
And these are
financial institutions.
The thickness of the line
is just how much there is.
In other words, the system
is knotted up together
in a big,
impossible-to-disentangle knot.
So are we stuck
with this system?
Is it the best we can do?
If we want to have
a financial system--
a global financial system--
where we have a global trade
and banks all
over, are we stuck?
We're not.
I want you to keep in
mind two analogies just
for understanding
what I'm about to say.
One is that banks' behavior
displays a form of addiction
to certain harmful things.
Harm to others in this case.
So even to the banks
themselves, when
you look at their entire
set of investors, including
depositors.
But they can't commitment
not to doing it,
because it's too tempting to do.
We have, inadvertently,
policies that
encourage them to do
those polluting things.
And then they do.
We have to push
back so they don't.
Analogy number two
is a speeding truck.
You could think of what I'm
about to describe to you,
for example, the
excessive amount
of borrowing by banks
as a way of speeding.
It kind of gets you there
fast if you're lucky.
But you're also taking a
lot of risk of blowing up.
In this particular case, if
you embellish this narrative--
or this analogy-- the trucks
have subsidized insurance
and their drivers get
out before the implosion.
They're OK.
But the collateral
damage is made.
But they will say, let
me get back in the truck
and drive again.
That's my natural speed.
That's the kind of
bankers' new clothes.
The question will ask about
an ounce of prevention.
Can we put a speed limit?
Can we just stop that speed?
So what am I talking about?
I'm talking about putting
more equity in place instead
of their finding themselves
with a lot of debt.
So the bit concept-- it's
an accounting concept
so it's very scary
sometimes, but it's
a very simple concept-- is a
concept of a balance sheet.
A balance sheet has two sides.
One side is what
the investments are
and the other side is how
it's funded, basically.
There's borrowed money,
debt, liabilities,
and there is the rest,
which is the down payment
on a house, shareholder
equity, owner's money, equity.
Well magically, if you fund your
investments with more equity,
you are more resilient
to downslide.
Homeowner's saw that.
Companies see this all the time.
So should there be the
Pac-Man that comes and eats
some of your profits,
look at the bank
that people are
wondering if it's still
going to be able
to pay it's debt.
Is it solvent or not?
And look at the bank
with more equity.
Still around because the
debt's still in place
and it's the equity
that absorbs the losses.
And also that makes
the gain, that's
the fun part of it
when it works out.
Because then they pay the
debt and take all the upside.
That's the leverage.
That's the effect of borrowing
that magnifies the upside.
And the downside, should
there be another loss,
uh-oh, the bank could
become insolvent,
under water, like
homeowners whose
house is worth
less than they owe.
And now, all kinds of terrible
things are going to happen.
The government
can bail them out.
But in the case of
banks, there will
be all kinds of
disruptions to the system,
because people may have
run away from them when
they were afraid.
All kinds of other things,
they stopped lending
because they had to
sell their assets.
All kinds of the mechanisms
that we saw-- those of you
were paying attention in 2008,
or if you weren't, your parents
were.
So anyway, the question
is, why wouldn't we
have a more resilient
banking system?
Let's look at our biggest
bank, JP Morgan Chase.
If you look at the balance
sheet of JP Morgan Chase,
it has on one side
all kinds of assets.
They want you to think
that there are lending.
And that's their job.
They're lending to
the real economy.
God forbid, don't
touch their loans.
But in fact, lending is
only a very small part
of what they do.
Say JP Morgan Chase defines, in
their assets, the IOUs of all
their borrowers, their loans,
as part of their assets,
$700 billion.
The bank then has all kinds of
assets, derivatives in London,
all kinds of other things,
physical commodities,
you name it these days.
You will be amazed
what they have.
Lots and lots of things.
And a little bit of cash.
That the assets.
And how are they funding this?
$1.2 trillion of deposits.
This is money they owe.
They sometimes
forget it so easy.
It's our money when
we give it to them.
We don't give it to them
like normal creditors, that's
the beginning of what's wrong.
They love that funding.
Insure it and we just
trust that it's OK.
Trust that the regulators
protect us or something.
And then they borrow in any
number of very creative ways.
Overnight, against all
kinds of collaterals,
they call them repos,
we can go through that.
They find ways to
promise, to get somebody
to give them money in exchange
for promise to pay back.
And very little shareholders
money, equity, that also funds.
OK?
They have shareholder equity in
the area of under $200 billion
by shareholder's stock
price or whatever.
In the market capitalization,
they're not very large.
There are smaller than Apple.
They are smaller than
many other companies.
But by asset size,
they are the largest.
And this is through
accounting systems
that ignore trillions of dollars
of derivatives, just net them
out.
So they have ways to do the
accounting in such a way
that we won't even see
the actual exposures.
And I don't have time
to go through that,
but the book explains what's
off their balance sheet that
has risk in it that affects
them and everybody around them.
So they'll tell you-- if
you listen to Jamie Dimon,
he'll tell you it's a fortress,
fortress balance sheet.
Not the image you should have.
Not a fortress.
Extremely fragile and
extraordinarily systemic.
Too big to fail.
Incredibly messy.
Nobody can understand
what's going on there.
You can't read their financial
statements and understand.
You won't understand even
the Well's Fargo accounting
statements.
And people have tried.
So these are very, very,
very complex as corporations.
Almost impossible for
just about anybody
to understand, regulate,
control, all of that.
And the scandals every day give
you a hint of that as well.
So how much equity
should banks have?
Guess what.
In the Regulation of
Basel, what's called.
This is a city in
Switzerland where
they sit around and decide
on minimum requirements
that 27 countries are supposed
to impose on their banks.
The previous regulation,
coming into the crisis,
was that they should have
2%-- but not 2% of the total
investment, but 2% of something
called risk-weighted assets.
So this is where you
can ignore some things.
Like, for example, if
a credit rating agency
says that its AAA,
then you can just
think of it as good as cash.
Except until it's downgraded
and it's not so good as cash.
Or if it's Greek
debt in the euro,
if you're a German
bank or a Cyprus bank,
you can lend to Greece.
Don't have any assumption
that it might go down.
As good as cash, even if it's
paying 20% like junk bonds.
The regulation views it
as safe, because it's
a promise by a government, even
though the government can't
really print those
euros like Greece.
And Greece defaulted.
So they know we tell
you that they tripled
these requirements,
tripled them from 2% to 7%.
And you can go down to 4 and
1/2% of risk-weighted assets,
which for the Swiss banks
is like-- the denominator
of that percentage is like a
sixth of their total assets.
Because there's so
many assets that
get a very, very small weight.
And of course, those are
the assets they love.
If the regulation
thinks they're safe,
but they're actually risky
and pay a lot of return,
that's the place to go.
And they'll all go there and
get more concentration and more
interconnectedness and more
fragility in the system.
So I mentioned before,
the risk weights,
one source of fragility.
Bad regulation.
And now, because they
saw that the banks were
gaming this regulation.
This regulation, by the way--
Basel II-- was not implemented
in the US except, guess what,
for the investment banks,
the same investment banks that
got into the most trouble.
It was the deposit institution
because Sheila Bair, who
was the head of the FDIC,
didn't like those risk weights.
They basically kept them from
manipulating these risk weights
and playing with the models
of these risk weights
to get the equity as low as
they could get away with.
So now they put in a stop
gap measure, 3% in Basal III.
The big reform, 3% of total
asset has to be equity.
It used to also be that they
accepted some other things that
might be equity, might absorb
losses under some conditions,
and no such capital--
what they called--
absorbed losses in the crisis.
Everybody got paid.
Even if you were promised except
in this case and that case,
you were paid.
So when the banks
were bailed out,
all the creditors got paid.
Everybody who was promised.
These requirements, when I
looked at them four years ago
when they came out,
were based on nonsense.
Let me say the word.
Bad analysis, OK,
of the trade-offs,
misunderstandings, whatever.
Is it tough?
They'll tell you, oh, we tripled
the previous requirements.
Tripling almost nothing
doesn't give you very much.
So tripling this 2% to
risk-weighted assets
is still ridiculously low.
And in a review of
our book, John Cochran
said-- because we don't come
out with precise numbers,
because there's so
many issues around how
you count them, and how
you-- what's the denominator,
and how to deal with
risk, and all of that.
How much?
The point is you want that
balance sheet to absorb most
of the losses under
normal conditions.
You want them to remain safe
and to go get more equity when
they get down into distress.
That's what would
keep them functioning
so they don't harm
others when they fail.
Or they can have a more
orderly sort of intervention.
So I can go on and on about
the benefits of forcing banks
to fund with more equity.
Then we can ask
ourselves, why is it
that they hate it so much?
OK?
And there will be
reasons for that.
From their perspective,
it won't be
that complicated, many
reasons, strong reasons.
If you have more equity,
so many things are better.
They're less likely to default.
They're less likely to get
distressed, less likely
to have runs.
The downside will be borne
by the same people who
have the upside and not
by the rest of society,
not the taxpayers.
They won't need bailouts.
When they need to sell assets
because they lost a little bit,
they won't have to sell such a
big fraction of their assets.
If you have equity at 2% and
you lose a tiny bit, to recover
and have back to 2%, you have
to sell an enormous amount
of assets because you lost
half of your equity suddenly.
So your entire being, you're
not living on the edge as much.
The subsidies that
are associated
with being too big
to fail-- which
means that those who
nobody believes will fail
get creditors to give them
money under cheaper terms, which
is completely established.
And they still deny it,
but it's completely true.
And don't write as many
conditions and all of that.
So the ease with which a bank
like that can borrow-- just
like Fannie and Freddie
could-- with the backing
of the government
would be reduced.
In other words, you
will prevent them
from increasing that subsidy
to the stratosphere, which
is basically the worst kind
of subsidies we can give.
We want to reduce them.
And everything that
the banks do is
distorted by being so
incredibly indebted,
because heavily indebted
borrowers are just not
making good decisions usually.
They tend to love risk.
They tend to under-invest.
Homeowners that don't have
a lot of equity in the house
don't invest in maintenance.
That's why the foreclosures
find houses that are wrecked.
They won't give a
gift to the creditor
if they think they
might walk away.
Similarly, companies
that are distressed
are going to under-invest.
Countries that are
over-indebted under-invest
because there need
to be enough upside
to justify the investment.
Otherwise it's a
gift to the creditor.
And so, the dynamics of
overhangs is very intense
and risk is good.
If you are under water, you're
gambling with other person's
money and it's gambling
for resurrection.
The downside is just as bad.
And the upside,
you might be alive.
So there's reason
to take the company
and put it on the roulette
if there's nothing to lose.
So the borrower is playing
with the creditors' money,
basically.
And only can win from the upside
and otherwise the creditor
loses.
So the history of
banking doesn't
have as much
indebtedness as banks
have today, which is
always in the single digit
amount of equity,
however you measure it.
History of banking, if you
go back to the 19th century
before they had so much
support, so many safety nets,
is when there were
partnerships, the partners
had unlimited liability.
They had to cover their losses.
And they had 50% of the
investment of the bank funded
by equity and 50% by deposits.
So depositors needed the
bank owners to be there
or they wouldn't trust the bank.
Then as banks
became corporations
with limited liability,
meaning the owners
of the upside or the
share can walk away.
They grew and as you
put in, central banks
would give them support
against collateral.
And you put deposit
insurance in place,
so depositors didn't worry
about anything anymore.
The more safety nets you
put in place, the more they
loved and were able to
rely on borrowed money
to fund their investment.
And the more they resisted
putting their own money
at risk.
Why is that?
It was related to
that safety net
and to an effect that is
called a leverage ratchet.
It's a addiction to borrowing
that is always there.
A borrower always becomes a
bit addicted to borrowing,
will take my
another loan as long
as the creditor doesn't scream,
as long as it doesn't violate
the contract that they have.
By industry, I'll just
summarize this figure for you.
You'll find Google and Apple and
all these high-tech companies
at the place where they
just don't use any debt.
This is debt-to-total.
It basically depends
on the industry.
And we won't go into that.
I teach corporate
finance and we talk
about why you might
borrow more or less
but we have theories about that.
And no industry and no
borrowers in the economy
without any regulation
has as little equity
on a regular basis.
No health industry
lives like that.
And there is plenty of
equity to go around.
Most companies use
their retained earnings
as a first source of funding.
And retained earnings are
attributable to equity,
it's on-board money.
So if you are Warren
Buffett, you never pay out.
You just keep investing.
If they wanted dividends,
they can sell some shares.
If you have good investments to
do, you don't need to pay out.
Here are the facts.
Banks will tell you
they're so special.
They make long-term,
risky investments.
They're not special
in that, every company
makes liquid long-term
investments, very risky.
Often riskier than
making a loan.
Making a loan is not that risky.
You diversify a little
bit over the credit risk.
There is some risk
but it's not more
than other industries
or companies take.
It's just the way it's funded
that makes it so dangerous.
On average, by market
value, companies
have 70% equity,
at least ones that
have access to markets for sure.
And most of the
corporations and non-banks,
without any regulation,
just don't borrow that much.
If they did, they would
start having covenants.
They'll start having
all kinds of things,
even though they'll get a
tax advantage from borrowing.
Everybody does, corporations.
Yet, we don't see such levels
of borrowing with no regulation.
But the banks love to borrow.
Love to borrow.
Even when they have
under 10% equity,
they pay dividends,
borrow some more.
That's banks.
Why do they love
to borrow so much?
Well, the short answer
is, works for them.
Works for them on their bonuses.
Works for them on the ease
with which they can borrow.
Works for them to get
the upside while putting
the downside on somebody else.
Works for them.
And they can.
So why do they love to borrow?
Because it works for
them and they're able to.
Which is not the same for the
people, at least not as much.
So there is a leveraged
ratchet effect,
which affects all borrowing.
Once that is in place, the
same reason or incentive
for a heavy borrower to
take a little bit more risk,
the downside of which is
shared by the creditor,
at least if they can
walk away from the debt.
Means that once you borrow,
you want to borrow more.
So it becomes a bit addictive.
Usually creditors will
know this and will
put in all kinds of terms in
the contract to prevent that.
Because they know that
the borrower is playing
with their money
and will be tempted
to take another loan on top
of them or equal seniority.
But even if they take
a second mortgage,
they're more likely to default,
which harms the first lender.
So the creditors
always have to worry.
But banks are able to get people
to lend to them, for example,
depositors.
Depositors come in, don't
worry about anything.
We put money in the bank,
the bank goes and plays.
Takes the upside and then--
Compensation in
banking often depends
on something called
return on equity.
It's a whole culture thing.
And they always say that this is
their job, to produce returns.
Well basic corporate
finance says,
just taking risk
by itself, anybody
can do, why would I pay you
the big bucks just to do that?
Anybody can take risk and
get appropriate return
in these markets.
So the notion that your job
is to produce returns, well,
do you produce more
returns than is
reasonable for
the risk you take?
That's the question.
So producing returns is
not even an objective,
let alone makes any
sense as an objective,
if you don't adjust for risk.
The more leverage, the
more risk for the equity,
because it's leveraged.
So all this kind of focus on
taking risk-- basically, being
paid to gamble-- gives
bankers an incentive to say,
I got to borrow this much.
If you don't let me,
terrible things will happen.
That kind of thing.
So the scale is tipped for the
bankers in favor of borrowing.
Put the deposits in place that
we all need for payment system.
But now, the extra
dollar that they fund.
Where will they want to take it?
From that.
Never from retained earnings
or equity or not very much.
But all these reasons why
they like to basically mean
that it's cheaper
for them on account
of somebody else
bearing the costs.
They save but somebody
else is paying.
There's nothing about it
that comes out of nowhere,
there's no magic to it.
For society, what
would be much better
is if they fund with
much more equity.
So here's another
visual for you.
The bank can fund
loans-- suppose
we wanted the loans
that they fund.
You could imagine a company
producing just about anything.
And they need to get the money.
Well, they can get the money
from debt or from equity.
Now, the more debt
that they use,
the more they pollute
the rest of the economy.
So think of excessive
indebtedness
as a pollutant for the system.
Because it introduces all
these fragilities, few can pay,
then it cascades
through, and all of that.
Now what do we do?
We have policies in place
that subsidize and encourage
and enable more and
make the debt more
attractive to the banks.
They respond by
using a lot of debt
and just a little bit of equity.
And therefore pollute more.
So in other words,
we have a situation
in which we can get, maybe, some
cheap product if we subsidize
it.
Anything that you can subsidize,
you can get the price, maybe,
the subsidies to pass on, maybe.
But then, we've got
to clean up the river.
So how did we get?
The bankers are happy.
Do they pass these subsidies?
There's actually
a little evidence
that the more they
lever, the more
the rest of the economy wins.
Basically what
happens to lending,
in short, is you get
too much and too little
of it sometimes
at the same time.
Get them to love risky
loans, credit card loans,
they send everybody a
credit card, 20% interest.
And at the same
time, they don't want
to make the boring
business loan that
doesn't have enough upside.
So people would complain they
don't get loans, but then
some other people
get too many loans.
And they'll price the loans.
Making loans is an
investment anybody can make.
We don't know if they
actually pass it on.
What we do know is if you
look at it carefully--
and of course they have their
own industry-sponsored studies
that deny this--
there is no evidence
that economies are scaling
banking beyond $100 billion.
If you correct for the fact
that the bigger you grow,
the more subsidies you actually
have, so therefore your profits
are based on subsidized funding.
Once you correct for
that, there is no evidence
that the largest the bank, the
more efficient the bank is,
in terms of getting
product out of the bank,
getting work out of the bank.
There is evidence that the
subsidies-- which are enormous.
This shows you,
essentially, what
the banks would have had to
pay if they wanted somebody
to insure their debt when they
were so close to the abyss.
Of course, for insurance,
it's worth less in good times.
And of course, when you need
it, if you had to buy it,
you'd have pay a lot.
So the value of the guarantees
that the banks were getting
was enormous around the crisis.
They would have really gone
broke if they didn't have
them, many of them.
So what do we have?
We have a system where we
perversely subsidize pollution
even though there's sort of
a clean alternative funding.
Once deposits are in place,
you can always add equity.
You can buy anything with it but
it backs up your liabilities,
self-insurance.
And so the more indebtedness,
the better their lives are.
They produce more
average returns, maybe.
They get better compensation.
And we're drinking the
polluted water, basically.
So there's a large
cost to society
for these implicit guarantees.
The thing about
implicit guarantees
is you don't see
them all the time.
You think it's free to just say,
oh, I'll guarantee your debt.
In the book, we have a chapter
in which our homeowner/borrower
, Kate, has an aunt Claire.
And Aunt Claire
says, buy a house.
I'll guarantee your mortgage.
She gets a great
loan from the bank.
The bank doesn't care if
she puts a down payment
because Aunt Claire is rich.
But when Aunt Claire
tells Kate that she
can go build a corporation
and invest in anything
and she'll guarantee her
debt-- blank guarantees,
blanket guarantees-- she
can go to Las Vegas, too.
She takes the upside.
If it doesn't work out.
I mean, she pays dividends
to herself on the upside.
On the downside, she
just borrows more.
Until she ruins her
aunt, of course.
And we've seen countries
being harmed by this.
Iceland being one of
them, Ireland another one,
Cyprus another one.
That's how bad it can get.
For the others, it's
still incredibly costly.
So the big picture.
We want to shuffle the claims.
All investments can be done
if banks figuratively have
more equity.
I don't even care
that they grow,
as long as it's with equity.
They won't grow.
They will begin to respond
more to market signals.
Conglomerates in the
'80s, broke from being
bloated and inefficient.
And started being more
streamlined and more nimble.
These banks are monstrous,
inefficiently monstrous.
If they had to fund
in market prices
and not in subsidized way and
would have less incentives
to be so big and complicated,
in order to be too big to fail,
then we might begin to see more
efficient institutions being
formed for market forces.
Right now, the markets are
failing to correct all of that.
The incentives are all bad.
How do you make it work?
Well, it's a
challenge but you've
got to focus on
what you need to do.
First of all, they have
to increase their equity.
And they have earnings.
Just the other week,
the Fed, again,
allowed them to pay out because
the standards are so low.
Even in the US, when
it's 5% instead of 3%,
it's still ridiculous.
And it's by counting
numbers and all kinds
of weights and models
that you shouldn't trust
and all kinds of things.
I'll talk about stress
test in a second.
They tell you that
everything's OK.
If they are viable banks,
they can raise equity.
Anybody can at
appropriate prices.
They just don't want to.
They have to be
told, you know what?
Too bad.
The only reason you
can even live like that
is because people
believe you can't fail.
That's why people
give you money.
Go to equity investors and
see what they'll give you.
If you can't.
If you tell me you can't at
all have anybody give you
$1 or a euro for
your shares, I've
got to worry you might
be a zombie bank.
And Citi could be one of those.
Citi was brought back
to life multiple times
over the last
however many years.
There is it an institution
that's truly problematic.
Some claim it and
Bank of America--
the ones that made the
stupidest acquisitions
and lost a lot of
money, became insolvent,
and are only alive today
because of all the supports.
So Basel has lots of flaws.
This regulation is
not a good regulation.
They learned a few
lessons but not enough.
And there is a lot of bad
policies around banking.
They always kick the can down
the road, especially in Europe
right now.
They'll say, oh, we
can't get any bank fail.
We're just going to wait.
We're going to support them this
way and support them that way
and hope they make a loan.
But it's the weakness
of the banks that's
actually harming the economy.
And it's delaying
the recognition
of losses that already happened.
It's having too big a
blow to the system that
is filled with unhealthy banks.
That's really what's harming.
When they say, if you make me
a safe, lending will suffer,
they forget that
lending suffered
when they were unhealthy.
That's when lending
really suffered.
So all the narratives
are flawed.
The confusions in this
space are mind boggling.
If you were to start reading
about what's going on,
about the things
I'm talking about,
you wouldn't even know that
this is under discussion.
Because the word is not equity.
They use the word capital.
And then they attached
to it the word
hold capital, or set aside.
And then, so they'll say the
banks have to hold 3% equity.
Well, companies don't
hold their equity.
Other investors give them
money and they use it.
They hold assets.
They invest in things.
The whole set aside
makes it sound
as if the debate is about some
kind of rainy day fund, money
that you put in a reserve.
That's not what
we're talking about.
That 3% and 5% is just
kind of equity funding
that's plentiful for
corporations out there.
And that most corporations use.
And no problem in
the Silicon Valley.
Nobody borrows so much.
And so, they confuse the debate
with incredible nonsense.
Every dollar of
capital is a dollar no
put in the economy, set
in a vault somewhere.
That's not down
payments in a house.
That's not equity.
It's in the assets.
That's just nonsense.
But people don't understand
the word capital.
And so they think it's on
the other side of the balance
sheet, on the cash reserves.
So that's the beginning,
we're not even
on the right side of the
balance sheet in the debate.
And then other nonsense starts.
So in the document that sort
of-- if people don't have time
to read the book, we give a
list of 23 nonsense claims
that are made in this space.
There are many, many of them.
So you start implying
false trade of people.
And here's a classic
lobbyist claim.
More equity might increase
the stability of banks.
Might, admits Mr.
Ackerman, the CEO
of Deutsche Bank for a while.
The Jamie Dimon of
Germany for a while.
At the same time, it would
restrict their ability
to make the loans.
He says that.
That's just false.
To the rest of the
economy, it reduces growth
and has negative impact for all.
This he says after a crisis in
which growth suffered the most
since the Great Depression.
And not because they
had too much equity
but because they had too little.
The corrected statement--
the edited statement--
is if you have a well-designed,
capital regulation that
requires much more equity, it
will increase the stability
of banks, and it would
enhance their ability
to provide credit to
lend appropriately.
Not too much, not too little.
Make good loans, not any loans.
We have lots of bad
buildings in China and Spain
and Ireland, too much lending.
May reduce the growth
of subsidizing bank.
Maybe, but maybe it'll be
a better size for banks
and for the banking system
than what we have today.
So just that's OK.
And the effect on everybody,
except maybe for bankers,
would be good.
Then they start with
other arguments.
Some of these arguments,
other industries make.
Oh, you can't regulate
me here, because I
can't compete with the other
bank in Germany where they
don't regulate them, or
with the UK, or with China.
That's like saying, let
me pollute the river
because the other company's
polluting their river.
Or your kid might
say, let me drink
and drive because the other kid
is allowed to drink and drive.
I mean we don't volunteer to
be harmed so our banks can win
against some other reckless
bank somewhere else.
The successful banks
in Ireland and Iceland
did not help their people.
Then they'll say, oh, but
if you regulate us then
the banks will go to the
Shadow Banking system,
oh, into the shadows.
That's like saying,
don't forbid robberies
because my policeman is
only in the lighted streets.
But the robbers, alas,
go to the dark alleys.
Do we accept that or do we give
the policemen the flashlight
to go and arrest the
robber in the dark alley?
The Shadow Banking
system is filled
with bright sunshine
institutions-- money market
funds, hedge funds.
If we want to look there and
see what the bank guaranteed
to some special purpose
vehicle that came back
to haunt later on,
it's quite visible.
It's not in any
kind of big shadow.
You have to enforce
a regulation just
like you have to
enforce tax codes.
If you say, oh, there'll
be a tax escape,
then we'll cancel taxes.
I mean it's basically
an approach that said,
I have a Shadow Banking system
because I failed to regulate.
Therefore, I shouldn't regulate
because I'm so bad at it.
OK.
We can suffer the
consequences of not
regulating this industry.
And good luck to all of us.
But if we're going to do
it, we might as well do it.
So here are the
flawed narratives.
They're going to tell you
that stuff just happens.
It was unforeseen.
It was 100-year flood.
That's what they
want you to believe.
When Ben Bernanke talks about
it, or other policymakers,
you always hear
about how they're
helping the economy recover
and how they pulled out
all the stops to help
us when we needed it.
Just as if there
was an earthquake.
So that's where
they want to start.
What they don't want
you to think about
is how they failed to
protect us before that.
And how they failed to regulate
this industry before that.
And so that part is a
little less convenient
for them, and certainly
for the banks.
So if you drive at
90 miles an hour,
and then you can tell me that
it was just the fog somehow
and that's what speed
you have to drive,
then well, we've got
to deal with that,
we've got to suffer that.
But that's an act of
a natural disaster.
Or the narrative that there
was no problem of solvency,
of too little equity.
It was just a plumbing problem.
It was just some kind
of a liquidity problem.
I have the money but I
just didn't go to the ATM.
That's a liquidity problem.
So they were all really
strong but there was just
some kind of a plumbing problem.
They call it a
liquidity problem, OK?
That's again a way
to mask the weakness,
the structural weaknesses, is
to say, oh, the plumbing broke.
Instead of saying my
building was really shoddy
and that's why
the earthquake, it
couldn't withstand
any little tremor.
If you talk about
safety in banking,
the depressing thing is they're
going to be the stories,
and they'll keep
being the stories.
When airplanes crash, we do
not accept unsafe flying.
And there's only
so many narratives
that can be said about
an airplane crash,
except in Malaysia.
The black box-- or
orange actually--
will constrain
all the narratives
that people can have
about whether it
was a bird in the engine
or the pilot fell asleep
or the flight control messed up.
If you want to investigate why
something happened in banking,
they're going to say, well--
They'll tell you some story.
They'll have some model.
They'll have a narrative
which will just
allow them to not recognize
the shoddy construction
of the system and the
fragility of the system that's
entirely unnecessary.
So that's sort of
what's going on.
Now you'll read in the newspaper
that everything is fine
because they passed
some stress test.
If you were to look
at that, you would
see what a charade this is.
The benchmarks are
low, the whole approach
doesn't really take into account
all of the contagion mechanisms
that we know are there.
It asks, if I tell
you that there'll
be some adverse scenario, give
me some model about what you'd
lose and let's see what your
balance sheet would look like.
Let's not talk about
what would really
happen in a real
scenario and all of that.
But in any case, what's
the cost of banks
retaining their earnings?
Money still belongs
to the shareholders.
If debt is paid, no problem.
What's the cost to
society that they'll
be stronger like
other companies?
Bottom line, we had a major,
major financial crisis.
It's hard to know
what it would take
to cause more harm from
the financial system
to the real economy.
And that somehow did not
produce effective reform,
despite all the talking.
I obviously don't have
time to go over that.
When I tell you the
banks are special.
The specialness of banks
is what they get away with,
is really the bottom line here.
And there's no accountability
in the whole system, including
the bankers and the regulators
and the politician who always
love banks for
campaign contribution
or for telling them what
to do with the money.
And either are blind
or willfully blind
to what's going on.
So we wrote this book
to explain these issues
that I tried to pack
into however long I took,
I never look at the clock.
And since you're
still sitting here,
I'd be happy to take
questions or on the website,
bankersnewclothes.com.
There's lots of links to
excerpts and other things
but $5 for the
book, maybe you'll
want to become an
expert on banking, too.
So you, too, can know that the
banking emperors are naked.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So as I read
the book, the thing
I kept thinking to myself is why
do we put our money in the bank
anyway?
If you think about the things
they did when they first
were formed and you
think about today,
it seems like we're at
least close to having
an alternative for
store-of-value and payment
system, right?
So that kind of leaves lending.
But the question
is, as a depositor,
if I said I'm going to put
all my money in Bitcoin,
if enough people did that,
what would the impact be?
ANAT ADMATI: Yeah,
that's a good question.
So you always say, OK,
the system's not working.
Let's start another system.
And I am not-- with
respect to Bitcoin, I mean,
I do think that the
payment system is
incredibly inefficient.
So now when you just
talk about their product
and how they price
them and all of that,
there's a whole
other set of issues.
So is this an efficient
system of payment?
All the fraud, all of that.
I think they are just too
comfortable with this system.
The problem with
starting a system
is that whenever you
have a corporation
or an intermediary taking
money, you need the regulation,
you need policing of that.
So you saw even what happened
with an exchange of Bitcoin.
In other words, you
can still have fraud.
You can have a call-up
bank and there's still
governance problems.
So anytime you grow
from just people
bartering you have
a control problem.
And so the question is the
efficient way to organize it.
So right now, we
learn the deposit--
runs by depositors
can be inefficient.
Because depositors just get
too nervous and then they
want to pull their money out.
So we have deposit insurance.
But now we didn't
at the same time
counter the more has all
the problems, incentives
that it can create.
Or the ability to then borrow
more and more and more and more
and encumber the
balance sheet and that.
So my solution is sort of the
speed limit for the system.
In other words, as opposed
to throw it out the window
and try to start
again, because we're
going to go through some
of the same growing pains
that got us here.
It's just that we somehow
allowed the system
to get completely out of
control as it got more global
and all of that.
It was fragile in the past,
too, but for other reasons.
AUDIENCE: I didn't
quite understand this
during the crisis
period, but I heard
that big banks
like Goldman-Sachs,
they insured some of
their debt and then
they bet against
their own debt to fail
so they can recover
these things.
Many of these sounded extremely
counter intuitive to me,
in the sense that
they were betting
against their own
interest in many ways
to collect money back
from the insurers
because that somehow made sense
into their profits and so on.
Is there some reason
why that was also
contributing to things like what
led to the the banking system
failure?
ANAT ADMATI: I'm not sure what
you're referring to, actually.
I mean, if you're referring to
what's called credit default
swaps, what happened
with AIG was
basically that AIG Financial
Products, like a subsidiary
in London, was selling
hundreds of billions
of dollars of
insurance on credit,
on mortgage securities-- the
securities, pieces of paper,
that were backed
by mortgages that
suddenly were rated highly.
But then, there was some
correlation assumption
that was false.
Because the all failed
at the same time.
And all the things that
were supposed to be safe.
The banks, Goldman
in particular,
structured those
contracts with AIG
so that, as soon
as some rating fell
or whatever, AIG had to
post cash collaterals ahead
of everything else AIG owed.
And so the banks
were very clever
when they designed
these contracts.
Also with municipalities.
Look at Detroit and all of that.
So they always structure
it to protect themselves
as creditors.
So they know very
well how to do that.
And then, what
happened was, that
ended up interfering
with AIG's function.
And even though the government
said they won't bail out AIG,
then they did.
But the key thing to
understand about AIG
was that the bailout of AIG
was the bailout of the banks.
So that's how Goldmam-Sachs
got paid in full.
And everybody who took
credit risk with AIG.
Because when you buy an
insurance company from somebody
who can't pay their
insurance, you're
taking their credit
risk by that.
But AIG sold
insurance-- essentially,
earthquake insurance, insurance
that they really could not pay.
Assuming, you collect the fees
and everything looked great
until they had to pay.
And then, the government
had to dig them out.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
part of AGI?
ANAT ADMATI: I
mean, they all had
interest in doing all of that.
And the remarkable thing is how
it worked for them in the end.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
complexity a few times
during your presentation.
There was the balance
sheet for JP Morgan
that apparently
nobody understands.
There was this diagram
of inner-relationships
between different
national banks,
or banks in different countries.
There was kind of a
complicated graph.
So if I understand it
correctly, this system
is so complicated inside
the entities like banks,
and also between
entities like banks
and other financial
institutions, that pretty much
nobody really understands
the whole system.
So what's really
curious is that we're
trying to fix a system with
prescriptions of do this, not
do that, this kind of
regulation when we actually
don't understand the system.
So what are the
efforts right now
to simplify the system so we
can actually understand it?
And then we can
regulate it and come up
with prescriptions of
how to run it well.
ANAT ADMATI: Yeah, I mean,
that's a very good question.
I think that it was
clear in the crisis
that we really did not
understand the system.
And that's partly
why they said that we
need to bring derivative
trading into the light
because that's where a
lot of risk was hidden.
So supposedly there
are regulations
to try to reduce the
capacity of those markets.
But there is no way that
we really understand that.
The reason we say, here
is an obvious thing to do.
Hold their earnings
from being paid out
because there's no reason
they need to pay them out.
Is that's kind of the
no-brainer thing to do.
The other thing about
simplifying them,
the question is how.
So they're sort
of shining a light
on the complexity of the system,
seeing it a little bit better,
which some attempts
are being made.
I'm involved in the FDIC
Systemic Resolution Advisory
Commission.
These are the people
who are supposed
to take a Lehman
Brother or a JP Morgan,
in theory, into sort
of failure mode.
Dodd-Frank told them
to do that, and I'm
on an advisory committee.
And they tried to do heat
maps and things like that
and see what's going to happen.
And Paul Volcker sits
on this committee
and says it's going to
be a bailout next time.
You know, they're going to
all fail at the same time.
You can handle it.
How are you going
to negotiate losses?
When there's a
default or failure,
everybody runs for cover.
And who's going to be left?
The attempt here, that
I'm proposing, of course,
is to make sure
there's buffers so we
are less likely to get there.
And so should we get
near there, they'll
be less debt to pay and more
people to absorb the losses.
But I totally agree with
you that a big, big problem
with the system is
the great opacity
and the great complexity.
And you might, if you
want to be radical,
step back and say maybe we
shouldn't have global banks
because we can't have
bankruptcy courts that jive.
We cant.
We don't have loss-sharing
across countries.
Legal regimes are all different,
how they treat bankruptcy.
It's long and complicated
and convoluted.
And if you can't fail, maybe
you shouldn't be as you are,
legally.
But that's like a
whole can of worms.
They'll have lots of
lobbying about that.
Telling you that
big is beautiful
and we love them
just as they are.
AUDIENCE: Understanding the
evidence that your [INAUDIBLE]
prescription seems to be through
[INAUDIBLE] regulations, bank
[INAUDIBLE] to
have more equity--
or at least require them
to have more equity.
But a lot of people [INAUDIBLE]
say that one of the other main
reasons was the key providence
of the [INAUDIBLE] which
separated western banking from--
So, my understanding
is that the [INAUDIBLE]
because that's where people
have their depositories,
for instnce. [INAUDIBLE] And
investment banks are actually
larger and we can
[INAUDIBLE] fail.
So with that [INAUDIBLE] what
is your opinion on that and how
does that-- maybe that's easier
to bring back [INAUDIBLE]?
ANAT ADMATI: No, well,
the answer is one line.
Lehman Brothers was
an investment bank.
It wasn't fun to let it fail.
That's the answer.
We now-- Goldman Sachs is
a bank holding company.
Investment banks
were the ones that
were the weakest
even though they
don't have standard deposits.
I alluded-- and you may
have come late-- to the fact
that these structural forms
are very, very difficult
because the way Glass-Steagall
died was sort of a slow death
through all kinds of ways
that they found around it.
So Glass-Steagall originally
was not about risk.
It was more about consumer
protection, actually.
So it was about having
access to depositors
to sell them securities.
And it might have benefits,
if you would figure out
how to do a 21st century
Glass-Steagall, for governance
and for better
regulation of the pieces.
But it's still the
case that if you
were to do this, which
might be beneficial,
you still have to worry about
the leverage of the investment
banks.
So in other words, it
could be a good thing,
but it's not the only
solution that's for sure.
Because systemic
can be a hedge fund,
like LTCM can be
an investment bank,
can be an insurance company.
In other words, who are you
going to end up bailing out.
Doesn't come under
easy definition.
AUDIENCE: So to
flip it around, you
are saying that what
you're proposing
is a sufficient condition.
ANAT ADMATI: It's necessary,
not matter what else you do.
AUDIENCE: Got is.
So you're not saying
it's sufficient,
but it will work better
with something like--
ANAT ADMATI: The governance
problem of the banks,
in other words, is still a
problem in terms of the banker,
and the recklessness,
the fines they're paying,
all of those things,
so I didn't even
go there, to LIBOR
or to other things.
AUDIENCE: OK, about the
executive compensations,
I'm always puzzled by
two understandings.
One thing is, I think not fair
that they get tens of millions
in a CEO level, right?
Another thing, it's
my understanding
that it's a free market.
The company has-- they
have the free will
to determine the compensations.
Are these two things
contradicting or maybe
both can be right?
Maybe a surge, you know,
invisible variables somewhere
that I don't see how
they think about it.
ANAT ADMATI: That's a
really good question.
I come to baking from-- I
was not a banking expert.
I was studying corporate
governance and contracting.
And in particular, I was
interested in how corporations
govern, in terms
of their equity.
The problem in banking is
that much of the money--
so there is, sort of, how
do corporations govern.
And so you have, every
corporation has this issue,
there's a compensation
committee,
their CEO compensation
people talk about that.
Who determines that, say on
pay, all of those things?
For banks, what
makes it very tricky
is that you've got a
lot of claim holders
whose money is invested.
In other words,
corporations managers
always invest other
people's money.
The question is what does
these people have in return?
A debt contract or an
inequity claim or what.
Because banks have so much
debt, their shareholders
become a little bit conflicted
with their creditors.
Or the shareholders benefit
from government subsidies
because they get
to borrow cheaply.
So what ends up happening is
that at least the shareholders
who count or their friends the
institutional investors that
don't bother to really speak
up are benefiting from this.
In the end of the day, it works
for them at the ground level.
In other words,
the bottom line is
if they all do similar things
and if it doesn't work,
as they say, I'll be
gone, you'll be gone.
I mean, they come
back to the industry.
Everybody who borrowed too
much or took too much risk
in this economy suffered
except for the bankers
who took the risk and those who
were supposed to keep us safe,
basically.
So somehow, accountability
at the ground level
is not really working.
And if you work up
the governance chain,
you really see the conflicted
incentives everywhere,
on every level, including
even auditors, which
was sort of the Enron problem.
So it's kind of a depressing
note about how governance works
and doesn't, but especially for
banks, it works very poorly.
[APPLAUSE]